[Musique]
il fait deux ans que je rêve de voir
tout ce que je touche se transforme en
échec ce n'est pas david bowie papa tu
sauras jamais moi j'ai trouvé plus
dépressifs mangent à l'invasion du je
m'appelle delphine je suis alcoolique ce
qui m'a sauvé c'est mon équipe de
natation synchronisée masculine un
secret que je veux dire un point dans
cette équipe et soigner la volonté la
grâce leur étude est une grande hygiène
de vie je m'en sens capable de ça bon tu
sais nager au moins ça c'est dans
l'équipe
[Musique]
clinton porte en championnat du monde
un fantasme pied pour aller titiller les
équipes de france et pourquoi pas les
hommes dauphin vous croyez c'est comme
ça vous allez gagner juste participer on
arrête de rigoler vous avez tous sous ma
tente et on va aller courir je suis pas
mes habits pour courir il faut faire
on va chercher la fille qui est en moi
ya pas de filles ont moins bien sûr que
si et brut est encore un petit truc pour
autant au contraire tangara peut-être un
peu
[Musique]
ça vient pas l'ange non j'ai mis le
temps passant
[Musique]
drôle
ça n'empêche pas la moins fort
moi je n'aime pas ce qui se raconte
autour de lui mais c'est mon mec et je
suis fier de lui
[Musique]
c'est important d'être philo sur le fond
c'est que vous avez peur mais on est là
et puis vous dire aussi que vous m
[Musique]